こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーと
まさき取締役です
今日は
非常に真面目な話があります
あの、ホントに
笑い無しで
聞いてほしい、と思っております
実は私はじめしゃちょーですね
まあ、大学も卒業して
社会人になって
まあ大学時代は
大学に行くことが多かったので
まあ大学に車停めるところもないし
バイクでいいかなと思って
ずっとバイクに乗ってたわけなんですけど、も
あのー実は
ちょっと前に
車を購入致しまして
あ、はいここは拍手するところですね
ありがとうございます
いやー、ホントまさきにもね
乗せてね、一緒にどこか出かけたりさ
動画で何か物が必要になったという時
すぐ、物を運べたり
たまーに東京にね、車でこう、行ったりね
すごい快適で
まあ、ちゃんと卒業もしたし
社会人としてね
車があって……
もいいかな、と思って
買って
まあ乗ってたわけなんですけど　も
ふざけるとこじゃない
マジな・・・
マジな、ホントの
あのー、ホントの話をさせていただきますとー
車のマフラーが
排気ガスが出る
車のマフラーという部分があるんですけども
なんでー
なんで盗まれるの
いや　盗まれるだろうなと思ったからさ
盗まれたりイタズラされるだろうなと思って言わなかったけどさ
言わなくてもされるって　もう
どうすればいいの
ホントに
何
ホントにタチ悪い人がいるなと思いまして僕は
ガチの犯罪だからね
ガチの普通に
盗んだ奴らお前ら見てるか
マジの犯罪だからな
悪いけど、警察に言いに行きますから
ホントに困ってます
どうすればいい？
一回も動画じゃ言ってないし
乗ってるところもそんなに見られてないよね
うん・・・
で、マフラー無くなってんだよ
どうすればいい
ホントに笑い事じゃない
笑い事じゃないよ本当に
いやー割とホントに
深刻な問題です
なんでそのー、車が何かっていうことも
言わない方がいいな、と思って
今まで言ってこなかったんですけども
盗みは普通に犯罪ですので
もし盗んだ人
この動画を見てると
僕のマフラーを返してください
非常にかっこ悪いです　今
マフラーも高いんですよね、でも
マフラーだけ・・・
交換とか、買う人っていないから
いないからそんなの
さっきまで落ち込んで
なんか今まで出会った人たちの歴史みたいなのずっと見てました
みなさん逆にどうすればいいと思います、こういう事件
逆に聞きたいよね
乗ってたら盗撮されそうだしさあ
乗ってなくても盗撮されるし
もうホントに迷惑なんで
できれば
盗みはやめてほしいです
できればじゃないわ
普通にやめてほしいです盗みは
というわけで、まあマフラーを盗んだ人いたら
正直に言って頂いて
返してくれると
ありがたいです
という感じで車の問題をどうするかだよね　今後
もう一度　道徳について考え直してほしいですよね
例えばね、車に乗ってる男の人がいると
その人の車のパーツが盗られて
男の人はどう思うか
嫌な気持ちだよね
それと同じだよ
今回はね、ちょっとこんな悲しい話になってしまいましたが
マジ買ってそんなに日が経ってなくて
マフラーは無くなりました
まあでも車買ったってデカいよね
イベントっていうことでいったら
一応それはちゃんと言っておきます
車は買って
まあ移動とかも結構ね
しやすくなっております
なんかこんなんがしゃべってる動画だと思われてますけど
普通に大犯罪が起こったので
あのホントにね悪いことは悪いです
駄目なことはダメです
マフラー盗んだ犯人
出てこいやー（高田信彦風）
真面目よ